men don't actually understand that if you have these three qualities about you
you can lock down any high value woman you want
you see drop dead gorgeous smoke show women sometimes with average looking men
and then you're probably asking yourself what does he have that I don't have
and then you probably said on the idea that oh it must be because he's rich
oh that's not necessarily the case
maybe it can be in some
but I'm not saying it's always the case
Wanna know what the most attractive qualities a man can have is
no you don't have to be the most attractive guy physically
you don't have to be the biggest guy in the room
and you don't have to be an alpha
instead if you wanna high value woman
you need to possess a perfect balance of confidence
peace and safety
that's what these high value women are looking for in a man
number one confidence
you're able to get things done
especially when problems arise
number two peace
meaning you're able to create a peaceful environment for
where she never doubts that she's being heard or seen
it's all women want is to be understood and loved
she knows that her heart is safe with you
because you've created a peaceful environment for her
three lastly
you're protective over her
not only does she know that you protect her heart
but you also protect her safety
situations where her safety is at risk
you step up and protect her
so next time you see an average looking guy with a gorgeous girl
you can probably assume that it's not because he has money
instead
it's because he has these three qualities that every woman looks for in a man
and this could be you
you could be a high value man with these three qualities
and get a high value woman